we can paint a horizon with a single
brush stroke it signifies the boundary
of our site a ship sailing over the
horizon won't stop existing once it
passes it and the sailors wouldn't
notice it's just us onlookers back on
the beach who will think the boat has
disappeared the same is true for the
Horizon of a black hole if our friend
Carlo was to travel to a large black
hole and managed to cross the Event
Horizon he wouldn't even notice super
massive black holes are large enough
that changes in gravity are spread out
and they are less likely to hurt you
it's only the small black holes you need
to worry about they could turn you into
spaghetti because gravity's well is very
steep Carlo's watch continues ticking at
its normal rate but to us watching from
the outside he would slow to a stop past
the Horizon Carlo would disappear from
our sight because the light from him
could no longer reach us but Carlo
himself would be happily bobbing along
deeper into the black hole